you know president zielinski the leader
of ukraine he warned that the russians
would intensify their attacks this week
this as ukraine waits for a decision
from the european union on its candidacy
for membership in the european bloc and
you know president putin has said look i
don't have a problem with uh
with ukraine joining the eu but uh i
think events on the ground
suggest otherwise what is happening in
savera donetsk and it's twin city
lucidcharts some of the heaviest
fighting some of the heaviest shelling
that we have seen since the war began
and what we have heard from a local
governor is that the russians have moved
into a local village one of the villages
which surround these two cities called
toshkivka does sound like they are
making some limited progress we just
spoke to one of the commanders commander
of the svoboda battalion they are
fighting right in several donetsk for
the ukrainians he said the front line
hasn't actually moved but he said the
shelling was the heaviest that they have
experienced he said it is raining shells
in sabro donetsk at the moment and we
also spoke to the police chief in the
city just across the river and
lucidchart his name is oleg grigorev
we we did a video call with him because
we were asked we wanted to ask for an
interview with him he was in a bunker
he did not look very happy at all he
said the shelling was very happy and he
said he would speak to us tomorrow if
they survived it that's horrific john um
i just mentioned it earlier when i was
introing you but why is lithuania now
being dragged into the conflict
yeah this is a good question there there
is a flash point there
a mark or a point of tension and that
has really broken out into the open what
has happened is that the eu is has moved
to implement a ban on the impla on the
transport of goods from russia
and we're talking about things like
metals and coal and computer technology
that sort of stuff basically that kind
of stuff is not supposed not allowed to
move into european or eu territory there
is this bit of russia this slither of
russia on the baltic sea called
kaliningrad sandwiched between poland
and lithuania there is agreement that
allows
people and things to move between russia
proper and kaliningrad and now the
lithuanians say look we're just
implementing this ban we're implementing
this eu ban on all goods on our
territory going to clean and grad
the russians are very very unhappy about
this the governor of kaliningrad says
look this is 50 of everything we import
that you're telling us we can't that
you're going to ban now and the russians
in moscow very upset as well the
vladimir putin's spokesman dmitry peskov
he said the situation is more than
serious he said they're going to think
about it very carefully before they take
counter measures and here i'll just show
you here's a tank going by
if you can see it that that
yeah that road leads to severo donetsk
we have seen a lot of heavy equipment
moving east that was one of them they
often come by in long long convoys tanks
a precious commodity for the ukrainians
they don't have that many of them they
are sending them into battle i think it
is fair to say that a fight has really
intensified
in the donbass in and around cervero
donetsk and lucy chansk over the last
couple of days